[Music]
it's pretty chaotic here on the first
day because nobody knows where to go
there's 50 000 people showing the first
day probably about 250 000 by the time
this is over and it's really going to be
big this year because there's so many
institutions interested
this is the first time there's been so
much policy proposed it's going to make
crypto really what i think will be the
12th asset of the s p the 12 sectors
coming up yeah there's so much
productivity available with this
software because bitcoin's just a
software all of this stuff is soggy and
that's why the world is gathering here
to talk about hey mr wonderful here with
the world opening backup every guy needs
to invest in how they're presenting
themselves that's why i'm excited to
have tiege hanley as a sponsor of
today's video you've heard me talk about
them before and i'm going to keep
talking about them because they use
their products look i'll admit skin care
wasn't something i always focused on
but since i started using their system
i've seen improvements in the way my
skin looks and feels and it kind of
helps me present myself i want to look
good i recommend you start with their
level 1 system here it is right here
which comes with all the basics a daily
face wash an exfoliating scrub an am
moisturizer with spf 20 is a big thing
for me that's what keeps the dome safe
and a pm moisturizer keeps the skin
moist one thing i appreciate about teeth
handling is how they make it easy they
give you an instruction card that tells
you when to use each product how much to
use and what order you don't have to
take my word for it because they have
over 5 000 five-star reviews from
satisfied customers all around the world
also tiege hanley members get tons of
benefits including at least twenty
percent off the retail price
free us shipping access to exclusive
monthly deals try the level one system
which comes with all the basics a daily
face wash an exfoliating scrub an am
moisturizer with spf 20 and a pm
moisturizer for while you sleep all for
30 bucks which is super affordable and
they ship it right to you and because
tiege hanley is sponsoring today's video
they're offering my viewers a great deal
just click the link in the description
and not only will you get tiege hanley
for the best possible price i love that
but they'll also give you a free gift
with your first box
click that link and get started today i
don't endorse products i don't use but
this am spf 20 keeps the dome of desire
looking just
[Music]
wonderful
check out tiege hanley
it's all about skin and how you feel and
how you look biden is talking about a
wealth tax now and taxing unrealized
gains
for most entrepreneurs in america that
is an un-american idea but this plan is
d-o-a in my opinion not a chance this
happens and that's a good thing at this
point i like gridlock in washington
we've had enough spending let's end it
now and let's coast in for the next 36
months with nothing else done that would
be good what i think is going to happen
in the next 24 months is this new
generation of minor
very similar to bit zero
they are going to go to the public
markets and so you're going to have an
option you can buy a dirty miner on the
public exchange or you can buy a clean
miner the only way to own a clean miner
right now is you got to go in privately
and get a position but they're all going
to tap the public markets so you know
bit cereal is just one of the positions
i'm going to buy others too
but
for me owning the
actual miner is no different than owning
the miner for gold you get leverage
how's the environment in canada
way more progressive
regulators so much advanced i see a lot
of businesses and i try and give good
advice
the market's a tough place and the
crypto markets are even tougher i can't
believe that you can have a democrat
sitting beside a republican
working on something together when's the
last time that ever happened literally
looking at the nfc space as as a
authentication vehicle for hard assets
like watches which i'm a huge watch
collector i want to own the
infrastructure
of nfts and that is jordanfree with his
nft.com i own a big whack of that i just
like what he's doing in terms of
providing liquidity to all nft markets
and so for me it's trying to find those
winners find those innovators and place
bets here and there
thank
and i'll go ahead and get you miked
perfect thanks
one for mr o'leary with a headset mic
you know what i want to talk about i
want to talk about bitcoin increasing in
value dramatically when institutions
start buying it why are they not buying
it because they don't have policy yet we
need policy that's what i'm going to be
talking about and then it's to the moon
and to celebrate that i'm wearing my
snoopy to the moon this is a fantastic
omega you know this little guy this
watch has gone crazy because everybody's
talking about going to the moon well
we're going to go to the moon but we
need policy
all about policy hey regulation's okay
when you make money on it
all right
thank you everybody
i want to talk about indexing for a
moment now many of you know what that is
if you're an institution but let's say
you're a very very wealthy middle east
sovereign fund and you're managing i
don't know 500 billion dollars
and you don't need any more oil as an
investment because you've already got
that in the ground so you go to an
indexer like me and say look give me the
s p less energy less airlines and that's
what indexers do
so we as an industry get to see fund
flows 24 7 every day and there are
billions of dollars out there
waiting
for policy because
for all the excitement about bitcoin for
all the excitement about crypto for all
of the wonderful productivity these
products and blockchain and everything
that's promised that you're going to be
hearing about the next three days
these massive pools of capital
these trillion dollar pools
own
this much crypto
this much
practically nothing it's the purvey of
high net worth individuals hedge funds
and retail investors and that's okay
but what we're missing
is policy
when we get policy and the regulator
regulates that's not a negative thing
the spigots of capital
are going to flood into this sector
like you've never seen and so for those
of us that can invest in it now you're
getting ahead of what's going to be a
huge wave of interest when policy occurs
i predict in the next 10 years that
crypto blockchain
bitcoin
all of this innovation
will be the 12th sector of the s p
now why do i say that because
bitcoin is not a coin it's software
ethereum is software avalanche is
software helium is software salon is
software it's all software and the
smartest hands-over keyboards today
in the world
are developing on the chain and bringing
innovation to financial services which
in the end is the largest sector on
earth
now what we need is policy we need
government to catch up with us
so that we don't lose leadership in
america to this very important 12th
sector of the economy there's no
question so let me give you
a quick update because i've been
spending a lot of time in washington in
the last three months a lot of time
and the good news is on a bipartisan
basis there are many senators and reps
that are thinking about this in a
proactive way so i'm going to give you
what i'm calling the five vectors of
policy
and give you an update of where we're at
on this stuff because i've actually read
these bills
they're big
a lot of reading a lot of bedtime
reading here
but there's a lot of good innovation
occurring let's start with the big daddy
bill that's coming out of cynthia lemus
she is coming here
on friday to give a keynote
this is a very important milestone to
have a senator come here and address
this important sector with a bipartisan
mandate that signals that regulation is
coming and that is a good thing
that's vector number one vector number
two
the president himself
in his direct order his executive order
talked about krypto was something that
he wouldn't
make illegal that was most important
message in there
but there was also a concern about
climate change we'll get to in a minute
then there's blackrock the larry fink
mandate that has discussed this sector
as well also a concern about esg and
climate change
last night at six o'clock
bill hagerty
dropped a bill
two pages
i spoke to the senator last night a
two-page bill that would make stable
coins legal
this is a genius piece of legislature
if it's two pages every senator can read
it and it's very simple
what this says is this
why is this any different than a money
market fund
why can't we have
a simple audit every 30 days with the
underlying security inside of it whether
it be usdc or any other stable coin and
why can't we limit the duration of the
asset to 12 months or less and then why
don't we let the market compete
to provide stable coins which are now
way past 100 billion dollars and allow
institutions to put this on their
balance sheets
two-page bill
[Music]
there's a senator that wants to do
business i of course applaud this
mandate because my own auditor won't let
me in my operating company do anything
with stablecoin because there's no
regulation on it so maybe the best way
to approach this for all of us they're
interested in crypto is to pick one
pillar of value and right now i would
argue that stable coins are one of the
fastest growing asset classes outside of
bitcoin
and help this become policy and law and
watch what happens and the reason you
should care is if it's backed by the us
dollar
it will become the reserve currency of
the earth that's what will happen and
why would we want to give that up to any
other country why would we ever give
that innovation up so let's regulate
this let's get behind this
bill and make it happen
and i'm not asking the federal
government to write one line of code
that's not their job let the free market
let the private sector develop these
stablecoin products and let them compete
just like fidelity competes with their
money market fund like schwab competes
they're regulated and everybody uses
them when they have a cash balance on
their account let's do the same thing
here
that way we have the innovators coding
and we have the government regulating
that's a great outcome
it's coming soon now let's talk about
the minefields in the five vectors of
policy
we'll start with the sec
now i don't know if you read
these memorandums but a few weeks ago
they started proposing that in addition
to financial audits in all companies
that are public in all 11 sectors of the
economy
that they have a carbon audit that they
get somebody if you claim that you're
carbon neutral
you're going to get audited every
quarter
now in the bitcoin mining industry where
i'm a participant
the way we get carbon neutral is we buy
carbon offsets
the problem with a carbon offset is the
tracking error is so huge that no public
auditor
will sign off on those statements you
can say you're carbon neutral but
there's nobody going to sign it at the
risk of being offside with the sec so if
the sec adopts that policy that's bad
for proof of work and it's bad for
bitcoin mining because the first
pioneers of this
in the u.s
were very concerned about being esg
compliant and they went to that market
they went to the offset market two weeks
ago in the eu they tried to ban
proof of work
because they were so concerned about how
much carbon it was doing now here's why
bitcoin mining is going to save the
world
if this policy gets implemented because
it's also in the esg mandate that larry
think of blackrock put in place and it's
also mentioned directly deep in the
executive order of the president himself
it's a direct swipe at bitcoin mining
but why is bitcoin mining good for the
earth because the next generation of
bitcoin miners and some of them are
represented right here
are starting to work with energy that
does not require carbon hydroelectricity
and nuclear power wind and solar the
drive to produce bitcoin is so economic
in value that they will go ahead and
fund the next generation of machines and
turbines 90 of dams built in america in
the last 100 years contemplated
hydroelectricity but never installed the
turbines
i'll install the turbines why because
it's great economics if i can use that
and not be hassled by a carbon audit
this is the future of bitcoin mining we
will be developing power
for all communities while we mine coin
in an ethical and 100 percent green
mandate that we can do
with hydroelectricity
this speaks to montana it speaks to the
tennessee valley upstate new york quebec
canada northern norway all of these
places georgia have an abundance of
unused hydro and that is the future
of bitcoin mining
and it's a good thing
it provides for communities it provides
extra power
and the capital required for this is
unlimited
now the beautiful strategy here is when
we get policy
this is the loomis bill right here
and there's lots of good news in this
thing when we make
bitcoin
an allocation for institutions which
they do not have yet what i predict will
happen they will put between 50 basis
points and three basis points or 300
basis points into their portfolios
how much money is that
trillions of dollars
so if you want to see bitcoin appreciate
in value if you're an advocate like i am
because it's software and it's a
property and maybe it's a currency you
want regulation you embrace this and you
stand back and watch the capital
pour into this
and to celebrate this idea to the moon
i'm wearing my snoopy omega today
that has snoopy going to the moon on it
this watch has gone up 4 000
in value in 24 months because of you
you love snoopy you love going to the
moon
you love this watch and so do i thank
you very very much
united arab emirates
brazil
switzerland
and those are the countries we're going
to with wonderful and we've applied for
our licenses in brazil already
we're about to do that in the united
arab emirates we just got back
if you want to get involved with us on a
global basis around crypto that's
probably the company to think about
senator loomis and hagerty the senators
here that are bringing policy and in our
universe they're all proposing
regulation so it may be a way if you're
interested in tying yourself to
um
you know a global crypto brand that's
that's regulated not rogue
um
that's what we could talk about that
might make sense i would love to talk
about that you know we can operate the
servers out of canada in the beginning
before we set up the data center in
cameroon to be set up overnight but he's
got to grant the license all right live
from bitcoin 2022
here's what's news
all the politicians are coming here
mayor suarez just left the lounge we've
got senator limits she's basically
making a keynote tomorrow that's never
happened that tells you that's signaling
that crypto is becoming policy
government is going to forge
new ideas for this because they realize
there's so much productivity it's kind
of like a turning point you can feel
this you can feel it here this is real
this is going to become the 12th sector
of the economy there's no question about
it
if you like that video wait you see my
next one don't forget to click right
over here and subscribe